well joining us now to talk more about
this technology is Torsten pahor he is a
trained psychologist and a researcher
from the Max Planck Institute for human
development thank you very much for
being with us today Torsen all right
let's start off by this it's a software
your opinion about this software can it
really help fight break ins what
apparently does based on what what the
person has told us about the success of
that tool it really was helpful in
decreasing crime rate to a certain
extent so based on that empirical data
it works and actually it doesn't seem to
be very surprising that it works because
the guys have done a good job extracting
from past behavior using all the
information the data that they're out
there other day out there to extract
regularities in the behavior of burglars
all right yeah you study how people make
decisions and judge risks let's talk
about criminal behavior and burglars
specifically how does a burglar make a
decision to rob a house for example and
what one of the studies that has
specifically looked at decisions by
bloggers focus when they make a decision
about where to break in is that they
consider relatively few pieces of
information about a potential object
where they could break in and these
characteristics specifically concern
first what can be gained from breaking
into a particular house were there any
signs that could people living there are
rich and on the other hand they also
consider the risk of detection so
whether there's an obvious alarm system
installed or whether there are there are
any bushes in there in the garden where
they could hide so they really try to
weigh the benefits and the risks when
making these decisions okay now that
sounds rather superficial when you look
at it from a moral point of view
what about consequence do criminals have
a different sense of consequence when
regarding their actions
that's one hypothesis in the literature
at least and there have been a couple of
studies that have specifically looked at
the weighing of risks by people who end
up in prison and the control group and
indeed some research has shown
that people who do have done criminal
acts have different risk perceptions so
there seems to be some difference
between these people and people who do
not act criminally right okay now you've
conducted its extensive research with
customs officials at a couple of
airports in Switzerland tell us more
about that work and what you found out
how do customs officials target certain
individuals so what we have shown in
this research is that customs officers
use very simple strategies when they're
making a decision about whom to search
at an airport and they also have to do
that because they don't have a lot of
time to consider a lot of information
about potential passengers who should be
searched and interestingly our research
also has shown that people who do not
have the same expertise as these customs
officers they use much more elaborate
strategies so this indicates that in
order to use a very simple and efficient
strategy you need to have knowledge all
right well we're gonna end on that
knowledge is always a good thing
Torsten thank you very much for this
discussion today it's been very
interesting